efectivamente maría clara es la primera
gira internacional del presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador
aunque ya había realizado tres viajes al
extranjero en tres oportunidades a eeuu
pero en esta oportunidad y como lo dijo
su canciller marcelo ebrard el sur es el
nuevo líder y esta es la política la
apuesta en 3 manuel lópez obrador en
centroamérica en materia de seguridad
fronteriza y de frenar el programa y de
presentar programas para frenar la
migración sobre todo porque este
fenómeno se está incrementando conforme
va decreciendo la pandemia en eeuu por
ejemplo la frontera sur ya cruzaron más
de un millón
gigantes y regulares desde que comenzó
el último año y aquí en ciudad de
guatemala ya arribó el presidente
mexicano con su comitiva del canciller
marcelo ebrard
y secretarios de seguridad y de defensa
su esposa y en unos minutos en cualquier
momento arribarán a mis espaldas al
palacio nacional donde se encontrará con
el presidente llama 'the para justamente
hablar de estos temas de programas
migratorios seguridad fronteriza entre
otros porque también abrirán un nuevo
consulado mexicano una interconexión
ferroviaria y programas para que la
frontera de guatemala con méxico sea
mucho más amable en nuevos cruces
fronterizos entre otras y cuál es el
impacto de la gira para eeuu
bueno es un mensaje claro a los eeuu
porque hay varios antecedentes la
llamada por ejemplo el show vaivén con
amlo en días recientes también la visita
que hizo marcelo ebrard a washington
donde quedó claro la diferencia de
enfoque migratorio que tienen los dos
países porque mientras eeuu dice que hay
que reforzar las fronteras méxico no
méxico propone abrir las fronteras pero
con programas de oportunidades de empleo
y son esos programas abanderados de amlo
en centroamérica que se llaman sembrando
vidas jóvenes construyendo futuro donde
por ejemplo hay más de 20.000 personas
reforestando diferentes zonas verdes
fronterizas sin embargo hay varios
críticos que dicen que esta
reforestación críticos ambientales nos
está dando propiamente con con árboles
nativos pero entonces es un mensaje
claro a los eeuu de cara a la cumbre de
las américas de que desembolsillar el
dinero prometido a los más de 4 mil
millones de dólares que la
administración by de navia from y de un
inicio que están congelados en el
congreso de los eeuu mientras que en
méxico sí lo está haciendo y así esto es
lo que está proponiendo andrés manuel
lópez obrador en su gira por
centroamérica